und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein 390 milliarden an
corona zuschüssen bei einem schicksals
gipfel auf dem es im grunde um die frage
geht welchen sinn eine europäische union
überhaupt noch hat wenn sie es nicht
schafft die größte herausforderung für
diesen kontinent zu meistern liegt am
ende die lösung offenbar in einem
uralten händler trick bloß keine glatten
zahlen damit es für die einen nicht zu
hoch aussieht für die anderen aber noch
hoch genug ist europas mächtige haben
ein so gigantisches coroner
hilfsprogramm auf dem tisch liegen das
ist schon komisch wäre wenn das jetzt
lautlos und rasant passieren würde
der kompromiss ist auch ein zeichen von
stärke wenn er denn gelingt in brüssel
ist die vierte gipfel nacht angebrochen
es gibt jetzt also wohl einen durchbruch
beim wiederaufbau fonds aber es gibt
auch weiter geben persönliche
verletzungen politische egoismen und die
frage wie sich diese union zwischen nord
und süd ost und west noch zusammenraufen
kann glück weil dort ein wenig
erleichtert wirkte der ratsvorsitzende
michelle als er am abend dem
verhandlungs gebäude eintraf vier harte
tage und nächte kaum schlaf kleinkrieg
um jede einzelne milliarde ein scheitern
hat er abwenden können vorerst
ich weiß dass die letzten schritte immer
die schwierigsten sind aber ich bin
trotz aller schwierigkeiten
zuversichtlich dass eine einigung
möglich ist die aufteilung von krediten
und zuschüssen im 750 milliarden euro
aufbau vor wurde geändert
von ursprünglich 250 milliarden kredite
und 500 milliarden zuschüsse auf jetzt
nur noch 390 milliarden zuschüsse die
nicht zurückgezahlt werden müssen
er kann sich als sieger fühlen der
niederländer rücke und seine selbst
ernannten sparsamen mitstreiter haben
sich durchgesetzt kritik der partner
lässt heute kalt er legt noch nach
im haushalt wollen wir uns für höhere
rabatte einsetzen und beim hilfsfonds
fordern wir reformzusagen der
empfängerstaaten und wir wollen hier
nicht endlos geburtstag feiern jeder
macht hier geschäfte für sein eigenes
land
druck der sich anscheinend auszahlt die
nettozahler dänemark schweden
niederlande und österreich sollen im
neuen haushalt hunderte millionen mehr
als bisher an rückzahlungen erhalten
allein der rabatt für österreich soll
sich auf 565 millionen euro verdoppeln
mit geballter faust in der tasche
verfolgten italiener griechen und
spanier dieses gefeilsche narrisch
musste wir brauchen doch eine antwort
auf die krise unsere bürger die
arbeitnehmer die unternehmen brauchen
zuversicht dass wir die folgen der
pandemie meistern können
bundeskanzlerin merkel und
staatspräsident micron konzentrierten
sich auf schadensbegrenzung darauf den
gipfel nicht krachend scheitern zu
lassen
aber die nächste verhandlung wurde
wartet schon im neuen haushalt sollen
zahlungen aus brüssel an die einhaltung
rechtsstaatlicher standards geknüpft
werden
der ungar orban und sein polnischer
amtskollege morawski machen da nicht mit
wir können hier einen kompromiss nur
zustimmen wenn die vereinbarung
keinerlei ermessens befugnisse für eu
gremien oder institutionen hinsichtlich
der rechtsstaatlichkeit enthält andere
gipfelteilnehmer drängen darauf dass
grundrechte überall in europa
eingehalten werden müssen
diskussionen über rabatte bei den
beitragszahlungen seien schon schwer zu
akzeptieren so der luxemburger battle
beim rechtsstaat seien sie nicht
hinnehmbar
diese war ihn zu einem europa wo
rechtsstaat und grundrechte verhandelbar
sind sagen wir nein so trocken ist war
vor einer halben stunde versammelten
sich die gipfelteilnehmer wieder im
plenum zu einer neuen verhandlungsrunde
wenn es ums geld geht dann sind solche
gipfel der tränen fast schon tradition
auch um dem wähler zu hause erklären zu
können man habe wirklich alles gegeben
wenn wir die show mal abziehen stefan
leifert wie groß ist denn die gefahr
dass der gipfel heute nacht noch
scheitert wer diese möglichkeit ist nach
wie vor eine reale möglichkeit denn eine
einigung ist erst da wenn wirklich jedes
detail verhandelt ist und davon ist
dieser gipfel noch weit entfernt das
kann also noch mal eine ziemlich lange
verhandlungsnacht werden so groß die
erleichterung darüber jetzt ist das ein
durchbruch erzielt worden ist bei der
finanzierung des corona fonds
so groß ist die hürde die jetzt
diskutiert wird jetzt zur zeit zur
stunde beim abendessen hier im gebäude
hinter mir geht es jetzt um die
komplizierte frage der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und diese frage ist
auch deswegen so kompliziert weil die
protagonisten ziemlich hoch auf ihre
bäume geklettert sind da ist auf der
einen seite viktor orban der mit einem
veto gedroht hat wenn so ein
rechtsstaats mechanismus kommt und auf
der anderen seite hatte der niederländer
mit einer art veto gedroht wenn es nicht
kommt dazwischen gibt es dann relativ
wenig raum für kompromiss außer man
verschiebt das thema man vertagt es oder
man findet einen wachsweichen
formelkompromiss die sorge hier ist
jedenfalls groß dass unter dem zeitdruck
unter dem der gipfel steht das thema
rechtsstaatlichkeit jetzt geopfert wird
damit es dann im laufe der nächsten
stunde enden endlich eine einigung gibt
jetzt sind die eu-statistiker stefan ins
archiv gestiegen haben herausgefunden
knapp zwei stunden noch dann wäre das
der längste eu gipfel aller zeiten
anhand der verhandlungslinien kann man
jetzt schon sagen wir am ende als
gewinner raus geht und wer als verlierer
also wenn man auf die nackten zahlen
guckt dann ist die bilanz eigentlich
ausgeglichen die südländer bekommen
einen milliarden schweren corona
hilfsfonds den man immer noch auch bei
den zahlen die jetzt wahrscheinlich
rauskommen wuchtig nennen kann
und auf der anderen seite ist es den
nordländern gelungen ziemlich saftige
rabatte auszuhandeln und das volumen
dieses fonds ja auch noch nach unten zu
drücken
eines der hauptergebnisse dieses gipfels
aber dürfte eine verschiebung der macht
achsen innerhalb der eu sein
frankreich und deutschland also diesem
franz deutsch französischen tandems
stand hier eine allianz von nordländern
und österreich gegenüber die doch
stärker aufgetreten sind als die meisten
das angenommen hatten hart verhandelt
ziemlich hartnäckig die positionen hier
vertreten und ziemlich geschickt ist
diese allianz in das machtvakuum
gestoßen was die briten mit dem brett
city auf der brüsseler bühne
hinterlassen haben
interessant stefan leifert herzlichen
dank nach brüssel allem was da
beschlossen wird wenn es denn
beschlossen ist muss auch das
europaparlament noch zustimmen
manfred weber ist der vorsitzende der
svp-fraktion der größten fraktion im
europaparlament guten abend herr weber
welches zeichen setzen die mächtigen der
eu denn mit diesem gipfel gerade an
europas bürger in not
erste signale dass sie sich auf die
gesamtsumme einigen können das ist ja
das wichtige wir sind ja mitten in einer
der tiefsten wirtschaftskrise
dieser kontinent seit 100 jahren gesehen
hat und in dieser zeit werden 750
milliarden und diese zahl ist eben nicht
verändert worden
bereitgestellt um die wirtschaft
abzufedern um zukunft zu schaffen das
ist das wichtige und das ist manchmal
mühsam ist da kann ich durchaus
verständnis haben 27 staaten die sich
treffen
27 parlamente die ihre positionen
vertreten aber ich stelle schon die
frage wo gibt es das auf der welt sonst
dass sich 27 staaten vier tage zeit
nehmen und ringen und kämpfen und
natürlich auch auseinandersetzungen
praktizieren und dann aber sich einigen
dass wir diesen wirtschaft schub geben
also insofern das ist das erste wichtige
signal aber wie schon angesprochen jetzt
stehen noch große fragen vor uns die
auch im europäischen parlament sehr
beschweren und offiziell beschlossen das
ist ja auch noch nicht herr weber sie
haben recht es geht natürlich sehr sehr
viel geld da ist natürlich klar dass es
reibereien gibt kompromisse geben muss
trotzdem drängt sich der eindruck auf
wenn es denn jetzt eine einigung gibt
dann gibt es die nicht weil europa so
einig ist sondern weil sich europa bei
dieser frage schlicht kein scheitern
leisten kann
natürlich gibt es diesen zwang es ist so
dass europa nicht scheitern darf
das wäre für die globale wirkung ich
habe die große sorge dass in 2 3 jahren
in china der große gewinner der korona
krise ist weil die wirtschaftlich
bereits wieder durch staat und europa
der große verlierer ist deswegen ja es
gibt keine option zum scheitern und
übrigens auch für uns deutsche nicht
weil wir können noch so viele milliarden
in der konjunkturpaket in deutschland
stecken wenn der binnenmarkt wenn die
europäische wirtschaft nicht insgesamt
wieder anspringt dann wird auch
deutschland nicht aus der
wirtschaftskrise kommen deswegen es gibt
keine option des scheiterns aber
nichtsdestotrotz muss man jetzt klare
kriterien weiter anwenden und deswegen
das bereits im vorbericht angesprochene
rechtsstaats verfahren die frage wenn
wir jetzt schon so viel geld ausgeben in
europa dann muss sichergestellt werden
dass wir in ganz europa unabhängige
gerichte haben
das unabhängige medien haben die genau
nachschauen wo werden denn die gelder
jetzt verwandt dass ich eine
zivilgesellschaft haben die die kraft
hat auch den machthabern mal paroli zu
bieten wenn es notwendig ist und das
wird für uns im europäischen parlament
wir müssen dem am schluss ja noch
zustimmen
das wird für uns im europäischen
parlament der zentrale prüfstein werden
und um genau diese verknüpfung mit dem
rechtsstaat verfahren
jetzt hier gerade in brüssel da wird
gerade darum gerungen und es besteht
zumindest die gefahr dass das unter die
räder kommt am ende diese verknüpfung
weil nämlich die mächtigen der eu sagen
hauptsache wir haben die finanzen
einstimmig unter kontrolle gekriegt und
dann lassen wir das mit dem rechtsstaat
verfahren mal und vertagen uns bei
diesem punkt wäre das für das parlament
akzeptabel
die europäische union ist kein
geldautomat es geht nicht um die frage
wieviel jetzt jeder nach hause mitbringt
um sich zu feiern statt schäfer sind für
sein land erreicht hat sondern es geht
um die frage wo ist europäische mehrwert
und wir sind eine wertegemeinschaft wir
sind nicht zusammen nur weil wir auf
einen gemeinsamen kontinent geografisch
zusammenleben sondern wir sind zusammen
weil wir gemeinsame werte teilen
und jetzt ist es an der zeit dass an
echten mechanismus zu machen der
garantiert dass das auch in der zukunft
umgesetzt wird
wenn ich wenn ich vielleicht mal ein
haken darf ganz konkret welche
druckmittel haben sie denn also drohen
sich jetzt hier heute abend mit einem
veto falls diese verknüpfung mit dem
rechtsstaatsprinzip nicht ganz knallhart
reingeschrieben wird in die beschlüsse
des gipfels
ich hab dann zum ausdruck gebracht dass
das für uns als europäisches parlament
für meine fraktion die christdemokraten
ein zentraler prüfstein sein wird ich
kenne das ergebnis nicht deswegen kann
ich jetzt auch nicht
weitergehende aussagen machen wir werden
das ergebnis genau anschauen aber die
staats und regierungschefs müssen wissen
dass das für uns wichtig ist wir können
die welt nicht hinausgehen nehmen sie
das beispiel hongkong jetzt wie china
sich dort verhält wir können die welt
hinausgehen unsere werte einfordern wenn
wir sie selbst im inneren nicht
praktizieren und übrigens gibt's noch
ein zweiter prüfstein das ist die frage
des rückzahlen mechanismus wird nehmen
ja jetzt schulden auf wegen der krise
und da sind wir dezidiert der meinung
dass man heute schon auch sagen muss wie
man die schulden zurückzahlt wir glauben
beispielsweise dass eine europäische
digital steuer die die amazonas und die
apples und googles dieser welt stückweit
daran beteiligt dass wir die schulden
auch zurückzahlen können dass wir auch
steuergerechtigkeit in unserer auf
unserem kontinent wieder erzielen
dass die jetzt notwendig ist und mit dem
geld ist da rein kommt können wir die
schulden dann auch tilton auch das
gehört zur ehrlichkeit dazu
mai die punkte werden jetzt in den
nächsten stunden noch verhandelt er will
bei ihrer haltung ist klar geworden was
wir noch nicht klar geworden es ist wie
genau sie die durchsetzen wollen am ende
dass sie dann auch zum erfolg führt
deswegen noch einmal die frage
wäre es ihnen am ende wichtiger zu sagen
wir brauchen diese verknüpfung mit der
rechtsstaatlichkeit also sprich kein
geld an länder die keine
rechtsstaatlichkeit aus sicht der eu
haben oder nicht mehr so viel wie
gewünscht haben und dann auch notfalls
verzichten auf eine gemeinsamen
beschluss zu corona hilfsgeldern
wir brauchen ein ergebnis aber
nichtsdestotrotz das europäische
parlament ist gleichberechtigter partner
wenn die staatschefs sich einigen muss
es bei uns im parlament zunächst
genehmigt werden es ist also mit dem
einigungs beschluss der staats und
regierungschefs die messe noch nicht
gelesen wenn ich so formulieren darf und
deswegen war ich wirklich alle sich das
mit der rechtsstaats frage ganz genau
anzuschauen im europäischen parlament
wird das für unser zentraler prüfstein
werden und dort glaube ich kann man
klarheit
alles alles sozusagen rauslesen da weiß
jeder bescheid wir werden es zum
zentralen baustein machen eine warnung
aus dem parlament manfred weber
herzlichen dank für das gespräch heute
abend ich bedanke mich soviel zunächst
zu diesem thema jetzt hat gundula den
nachrichten überblick über diesen montag
verteidigungsministerium kramp
karrenbauer hat bei einem rekruten
gelöbnis in berlin dazu aufgerufen
rechtsextremen tendenzen in der
bundeswehr entschlossen entgegenzutreten
im gedenken an die widerstandskämpfer
vom 20 juli 1944 legten angehende
wehrdienstleistende ihr gelöbnis ab wie
häufig im bendlerblock in berlin
dort wurden claus schenk graf von
stauffenberg und weitere an dem
gescheiterten umsturzversuch beteiligte
von den nazis ermordet kramp karrenbauer
bezeichnete das attentat auf adolf
hitler als aufstand des gewissens
der milliardenschwere bilanzskandal um
den zahlungsdienstleister wirecard
bringt auch die bundesregierung in
erklärungsnot der finanzausschuss des
bundestages will in einer sondersitzung
finanzminister scholz und
wirtschaftsminister altmaier befragen
unter anderem soll geklärt werden ob es
fehler bei der finanzaufsicht gab und
welche verantwortung scholz trägt
weiterhin gesucht wird ex wirecard
vorstand marschalek er soll sich nach
russland abgesetzt haben mit hilfe des
russischen militärgeheimdienstes
der kreml dementiert das im streit um
chinas sogenannte sicherheitsgesetz für
die sonderverwaltungszone hongkong
verschärft die britische regierung die
gangart nach den usa kanada und
australien setzt nun auch london sein
auslieferungsabkommen mit hongkong aus
mit sofortiger wirkung und auf
unbestimmte zeit
zudem wird ein waffenembargo das für
china gilt auf hongkong ausgeweitet
großbritannien kritisiert china
sicherheitsgesetz als klare verletzung
der autonomie hongkongs deutschland wird
noch in dieser woche knapp 100 kranke
behandlungsbedürftige kinder aus
griechischen flüchtlingslagern aufnehmen
gemeinsam mit ihren eltern und
geschwistern sollen sie am freitag nach
kassel geflogen werden
hintergrund ist ein beschluss der
bundesregierung insgesamt 243
schutzbedürftige erkrankte minderjährige
aufzunehmen
mitte april waren die ersten in
deutschland eingetroffen wegen der
korona pandemie hatte sich der weitere
ablauf jedoch verzögert um einer zweiten
corona welle vorzubeugen hat frankreichs
regierung die masken pflicht verschärft
ab heute müssen in allen öffentlichen
geschlossenen räumen und mund und nase
bedeckt werden
die neuen regeln gelten unter anderem
für geschäfte banken gotteshäuser museen
und sehenswürdigkeiten
bei missachtung droht ein bußgeld von
135 euro in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
gilt die masken pflicht bereits seit mai
in jeder situation die strotzt vor
schlechten nachrichten gibt es dieses
warten auf den lichtblick in der korona
pandemie sind es alle neuigkeiten in
denen das wort impfstoff vorkommt
idealer weise kombiniert mit dem wort
vielversprechend da können wir ihnen
heute etwas bieten müssen gleich vorweg
sagen es ist ein zwischenergebnis nicht
mehr aber eben auch nicht weniger
ob es der große wurf ist der mithelfen
kann diese welt von corona zu erlösen
ist noch nicht klar
mehr als 160 impfstoffe gegen das virus
werden weltweit getestet forscher in
großbritannien melden heute erste
erfolge und auch ein deutsches
unternehmen berichtet von 60 personen
die eine studienphase abgeschlossen
haben und von positiven ergebnis susanne
gelhard
es ist ein weltweites rennen um einen
impfstoff gegen das corona virus manche
vergleichen ist mit dem wettlauf zum
mond
das deutsche unternehmen bei montech in
mainz und das us-unternehmen kaiser
meldeten am nachmittag wichtige
fortschritte die zweite phase der
klinischen erprobung an 60 probanden in
deutschland zwischen 18 und 55 jahren
sei erfolgreich verlaufen ohne
schwerwiegende nebenwirkungen laut bei
montech entwickelten die testpersonen
mit hilfe eines neuen gen basierten
impfstoff sowohl antikörper als auch t
zellen die für das immun gedächtnis
wichtig sind
wir sind überzeugt dass beide
mechanismen eine wichtige rolle für die
wirksame bekämpfung von
krankheitserregern wie saas kopf zwei
spielen könnten erklärte slam tour de
ski mitbegründerinnen des unternehmens
wir haben ja zwei verschiedene emu name
das sind die antikörper und die t zellen
und die firma konnte zeigen dass
eigentlich beide arme gleichermaßen
angesprochen werden
wir haben sehr hohe antikörpertiter die
auch neutralisieren sind als das virus
in aktivieren
und wir haben auch t zellen von dem wir
weit von ihr wissen dass sie länger
aktiv bleiben dann knapp zwei stunden
später die nächste erfolgsmeldung dieses
mal aus großbritannien
dort proben forscher der universität
oxford mit dem schwedisch britische
pharmaunternehmen astrazeneca einen
impfstoff mit der sogenannten vector
technik dabei wird ein anderes harmloses
virus mit dem erbgut des corona virus
versetzt mehr als 1000 freiwillige
wurden klinisch getestet auch hier
erfolgte eine doppelte immunreaktion
durch antikörper und t zellen mit
geringen nebenwirkungen
ich glaube all diese impfstoffe werden
eine rolle spielen am ende bekommen wir
vielleicht verschiedene arten von
impfstoffen für unterschiedliche
menschen für die mit immun defiziten zum
beispiel für die etwas älteren oder für
diejenigen die schon symptome einer
infektion gezeigt haben
beide unternehmen wollen in kürze
weltweit mit klinisch
massentests auch in corona hotspots
beginnen schon bald könnte es einen
impfstoff geben so schnell wie nie zuvor
es gibt glücklicherweise viele
impfstoffe die aktuell entwickelt werden
über 160 impfstoffe davon viele über 20
bereits in klinischen studien die dort
getestet werden die ansätze sind in der
tat unterschiedlich und das ist auch gut
so weil wir wollen ja eine große chance
haben das wir am ende vielleicht nicht
nur ein sondern einige impfstoffe haben
die dann gut funktionieren und sicher
verabreicht werden können
bei einer zulassung möchte bayon tag
noch in diesem jahr in deutschland 100
millionen impfstoff dosen herstellen
über 1,2 milliarden sollen im nächsten
jahr folgen
die produktionsstätte in mainz wird
bereits gebaut und absolute transparenz
bei der prüfung und zulassung ist auch
deshalb so wichtig weil jeder impf
erfolg am ende ab hängt von der
bereitschaft der menschen sich impfen zu
lassen
unser nächstes thema frankfurt am main
hat einen schönen platz mitten in der
stadt da steht ein wieder aufgebautes
altes opernhaus da treffen sich börsen
menschen zum teuren after work drink so
war das jahrelang dann kam corona der
platz wurde plötzlich zentrum von open
air feiern mit viel alkohol bis tief in
die nacht dann kam das vergangene
wochenende und eine eruption von gewalt
polizisten wurden aus der menge mit
flaschen angegriffen und zwar offenbar
von menschen die in der mehrzahl gar
nicht in frankfurt leben heute montag
versucht die stadt das geschehene zu
verarbeiten und vor allem zu verhindern
dass es wieder geschieht wie erklärt
dominik löschmeister es soll sich
einiges ändern nach der krawallnacht am
wochenende am frankfurter opernplatz
schluss mit den dort üblichen freiluft
partys bis dann freitags und samstags
bereits gegen mitternacht so will es
zumindest die stadt frankfurt am main
durchsetzen
dieses deutliche signal geht gerade an
die störer die unterwegs sind dass ich
eben nicht lohnt hier in frankfurt
aufzutauchen
am opernplatz wird ab null uhr
beziehungsweise 1 uhr kein platz mehr
sein
die party war aus dem ruder gelaufen
hunderte junge leute griffen am
wochenende polizisten an warfen mit
flaschen 39 randalierer nahmen die
polizei fest die tatverdächtigen
inzwischen alle wieder auf freiem fuß
sind meist polizeibekannt es handelt
sich um personen die überwiegend im
alter zwischen 17 und 23 jahren sind die
39 haben überwiegend
migrationshintergrund aus verschiedenen
ländern her kommend es gibt da keinen
schwerpunkt zwar scheint es auch ein
integrationsproblem in bestimmten
milieus zu geben doch in frankfurt leben
über 50 prozent menschen mit
migrationshintergrund und corinna bringt
eine besondere dynamik
das betrifft natürlich bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen zu denen auch die
tatverdächtigen in frankfurt und
stuttgart gehören die in sehr beengten
wohnverhältnissen leben die sind davon
in besonderer weise betroffen
das heißt sie tun sich noch mal
besonders schwer sich an diese vorgaben
zu halten wie in stuttgart erlebt die
polizei auch in frankfurt offener
aggression all cops are bastards alle
polizisten sind bastarde liefen erst
jugendliche in den usa jetzt auch in
frankfurt erklärungsversuche
möglicherweise gibt es eben auch durch
die berichte aus den vereinigten staaten
über übergriffe der polizei auf menschen
mit dunkler hautfarbe oder auch die
debatte um polizei und rechte netzwerke
in teilen zumindest der bevölkerung
tatsächlich einen fernsehens verlust der
polizei die was dann dazu führen kann
dass menschen sich befugt sehen auf die
polizei los zu gehen
verbote allein werden nicht helfen es
braucht konzepte wie feiern
auch in der pandemie möglich ist unser
vorschlag wäre diese wilden partys
wieder mit den klubbesitzern zusammen
griff zu bekommen die klubbesitzer
könnten seit wochen monaten ihre klubs
nicht betreiben
vielleicht ist es auch gerade einer der
gründe warum sich das jetzt in diesen
wilden partys widerspiegelt die
generation corona braucht eine
perspektive
ein nächtliches betretungsverbote auf
den frankfurter opernplatz allein wird
wohl nicht ausreichen
mama nachrichten noch mal über die
korona bedingte krise der
fluggesellschaften will
bundesverkehrsminister scheuer in dieser
woche mit seinen eu-amtskollegen und
spitzenvertretern der branche beraten im
deutschen fokus steht da natürlich die
lufthansa die valerie haller heute eine
schnellere ticket erstattung angekündigt
hat warum erst jetzt
ja man sagt man sei von der korona krise
überrollt worden
die mitarbeiter seien mit der
bearbeitung nicht hinterhergekommen seit
april gibt es wohl die benötigten
kapazitäten bis zur auszahlung kann es
aber noch dauern manche warten schon
seit märz für die lufthansa ein
riesenbrocken bislang hat sie rund 1,4
milliarden euro ausgezahlt
offen ist fast noch mal so viel geld auf
das die kunden noch anspruch haben als
folge der korona pandemie war der
luftverkehr mitte märz nahezu
vollständig zusammengebrochen
tausende flüge wurden storniert die
erstattungen treffen die airlines hat
grundsätzlich müssen sie den ticketpreis
innerhalb von sieben tagen erstatten
viele fluglinien zahlen aber nur
schleppend in den augen von
verbraucherschützern hat das methode der
verbrauchten rückerstattung anspruch und
dieser anspruch wird ihm schlichtweg
durch untätigkeit verwehrt man hat hier
auch so wirklich das gefühl dass da ein
stück weit eine insolvenz puffer
geschaffen werden sollen und eben
verspätete rückzahlungen ländern
überhaupt erfolgen sollen wegen corona
war die versuchung groß das geld erst
mal in unternehmen zu halten jetzt da
die flieger wieder fliegen und zum teil
auch staatshilfe geflossen ist sollen
auch die erstattungen fließen
lufthansa kunden müssen sich aber noch
ein wenig gedulden vier bis sechs wochen
heißt es bis alle anträge abgearbeitet
sind
im rahmen der deutschen eu
ratspräsidentschaft will
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin klöckner
eine reform der eu-agrarpolitik
erreichen
bei ersten beratungen mit ihren
eu-kollegen zeichnete sich grundsätzlich
zustimmung für den green deal der in
kommission ab der auch die
landwirtschaft klima und
umweltfreundlicher machen soll
streitthema der kommenden verhandlungen
ist die finanzierung von klima und
naturschutz sowie der
lebensmittelqualität die lebenserwartung
der menschen in deutschland ist laut
einer studie im süden und südwesten am
höchsten das max planck institut für
demografische forschung in rostock hat
ein nord-süd-gefälle festgestellt so ist
die lebenserwartung für männer zb im
landkreis münchen mit im schnitt gut 81
jahren am höchsten und in bremerhaven
mit im schnitt knapp 76 jahren am
niedrigsten
starken einfluss haben faktoren wie
arbeitslosen und hartz 4 quote die
vereinigten arabischen emirate haben
erfolgreich die erste arabische
raumsonde zum mars geschickt bisher
gelang eine solche mission nur
großmächten wie den usa indien der
früheren sowjetunion und auch der
europäischen weltraumagentur und so
verbinden die emirate eine besondere
hoffnung mit alan wake countdown
arabisch zweimal wegen schlechtem wetter
in japan verschoben und dann dieser
bilderbuch start aller mal die hoffnung
auf dem weg zum mars angetrieben von
einer japanischen raketen ausgerüstet
mit amerikanischer satellitentechnik
beflügelt von arabische vision die
freude im kontrollzentrum für
emiratische verhältnisse geradezu
grenzenlos die emirate sind nun mitglied
im club wir werden mehr lernen wir
werden uns mehr einbringen und wir
werden unser raum forschungsprogramm
weiterentwicklung diese reise zum mars
ist für die hochfliegenden arabischen
pläne nur ein zwischenschritt
ab februar 2021 soll die sonde den roten
planeten umkreisen und wetterdaten eine
ganzen maries jahres erforschen der
hauptgrund für diese mission ist das für
die arabische und emiratische jugend für
naturwissenschaften begeistern wollen
deshalb der name hope hoffnung für die
arabische jugend vergangenes jahr schon
haben die emiratis einen landsmann zu
internationalen raumstation iss
geschickt jetzt also der griff zu machen
den wollen sie irgendwann sogar
besiedeln eine kühne vision anknüpfend
an die jahrhunderte zuvor als arabien in
der wissenschaft noch führend war und
das war dieser montag ist heute journal
in brüssel wird weiterverhandelt
ergebnisse wenn sie denn kommen morgen
bei uns in der sendung bedanken für
heute für ihr interesse und schönen
abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter den wärmsten juni
bisher gab es vergangenes jahr 2019 also
in diesem jahr ist der juni fast genauso
warm und besonders richtung sibirien
sehen sie hier dieses rot eingefärbt da
war die temperaturabweichung enorm und
in dem bereich im polarkreis da brennt
es heute schon wieder ganz schön heftig
das ist ein aktuelles bild von heute und
sie sehen hier die rauchwaren von west
nach ost das sind etwa 40 kilometer und
wenn wir uns diese region ihr anschauen
und noch vergrössern sehen sie hier
strukturen diese strukturen das sind
wolken dessen büro kumuluswolken die
durch diesen brand entstehen der brand
erzeugt quasi sein eigenes wetter von
solchen ausmaßen sind wir weit entfernt
bei uns gibt es eher ruhiges wetter und
noch letzte schauer im osten
deutschlands sonst klart es übrigens
meist im westen auf ansonsten
temperaturen bis 16 grad im südwesten
deutschlands als dessert und 6 grad in
der norddeutschen tiefebene morgen
entwickeln sich schauer und gewitter von
süden her bis zur donau etwa können auch
starkregen mitbringen ansonsten auch
schauer an der nordsee sonst ist es
trocken im südwesten vor allem dann
ziemlich sonnig die temperaturen
erreichen dabei 25 bis 28 grad in der
südhälfte nach norden ist es kühler am
kühlsten 18 bis 19 grad entlang der
küsten die nächsten tage im süden meist
noch gewitter nach norden erst mal
trocken 18 bis 29 grad am mittwoch und
am donnerstag dann auch im norden
schauer damit ein schöner abend